[Musik]
Russlands Oligarchen sind eine Klasse
für sich
[Musik]
obszöne Vermögen Skandale und
Geheimnisse prägen ihr Bild
ihren Reichtum halten sie für
hochverdient
viele Bereichen sind völlig davon
überzeugt dass sie so reich geworden
sind weil sie besser sind als der Rest
doch sie sind reich von Putins Gnaden im
Gegenzug füllen sie seine Kassen mit
ihren Öl Gas und Banken Milliarden holt
ihnen entscheidet wie dieses Geld
ausgegeben wird wo es investiert wird
und was damit passiert
mit dem Geld der Oligarchen finanziert
Putin seine kriege
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in Moskau herrscht die Symbiose von
Reichtum und Macht
an dem Tag als russische Truppen in die
Ukraine einfielen
alle großen Unternehmer zu sich
eingestellt
Freunde und Kollegen guten Tag
leider treffen wir uns unter gelinde
gesagt ungewöhnlichen Umständen
wurde gesagt russland hat eine
spezialoperation begonnen von euch wird
jede Unterstützung erwartet
[Musik]
ich appelliere an Sie zeigen sie
Verständnis seien sie solidarisch mit
der Regierung
[Musik]
wir lassen euch nicht im Stich aber ihr
müsst dafür auch uns unterstützen in
diesem Krieg und Loyalität sein
Putin und die Oligarchen dieser
fundamentale packt tritt mit dem Ukraine
Krieg in einer entscheidende Phase
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die heimliche Hauptstadt der russischen
Superreichen ist London in London Grad
haben sie Milliarden investiert und
leben abgeschirmte Nobelvierteln fernab
der Öffentlichkeit
die Soziologin Elisabeth schimpfössl hat
die verschwiegensten und mächtigsten
Menschen Russlands zum Reden gebracht
ich habe 80 Interviews geführt ungefähr
ein Drittel davon waren Milliardäre der
Rest waren Arme reiche Millionäre
manche trifft sie in London andere in
Moskau
sie erhol den Magomedov hat Milliarden
mit russischen Staatsaufträgen gemacht
er empfängt sie wie ein heimlicher
Herrscher da kam ich zur Tür und fand
seine dagestanischen Türsteher sehr
große eindrucksvolle furchterregende
Männer die haben wir dann zuerst mal
alles abgenommen ich durfte nur mit
einem Bleistift und Stück Papier rein
andere zeigen sich offener in
schimpfwessels Interview Mitschnitten
geben die Oligarchen Einblick in ihr
Inneres
fast alle sind stolz auf ihre
sowjetische Herkunft
sehr viele jene die gleich geworden sind
sind in Familien geboren die der
sowjetischen Intelligenz sehr angehörten
[Musik]
sind völlig davon überzeugt dass sie so
reich geworden sind weil sie besser sind
als der Rest weil sie intelligenter sind
bessere Gene haben härter arbeiten und
alles gemeinsam
[Musik]
die Ära der Oligarchen beginnt in den
90er Jahren
für normale Russen Jahre des Niedergangs
das tägliche Leben versinkt in Chaos
Korruption und Arbeitslosigkeit
viele kämpfen uns nackte Überleben
die Regierung von Boris Jelzin will die
sowjetindustrie mit ihren riesigen
Staatsbetrieben privatisieren zugunsten
aller Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ein Papier im Wert von 10.000 Rubel bis
zum Jahresende soll die Verteilung
abgeschlossen sein dann kann jeder mit
diesem Gutschein Aktien von
privatisierten Staatsbetrieben erwerben
[Musik]
die 100 Millionen kostet aber ein
Milliarden Potential hatten und jeder
der sich ernsthaft damit befassen wollte
konnte sich einkaufen
doch die meisten Russen geben in der Not
ihrer Gutscheine direkt weiter an
clevere business man die sie ihnen
abkaufen
der Diplom Chemiker Michael oderkowski
sichert sich so große Teile der
Ölindustrie
[Musik]
der Theaterregisseur Wladimir gustinski
wird zum Banker und Medienunternehmer
borisowski ein studierter Mathematiker
macht sein Vermögen in privatisierten
Autohandel
im Kreml unter Präsident jelz hingehen
sie ein und aus sie leihen dem
bankrottenstart Geld und Steuern mit
ihren Medien die öffentliche Meinung die
Oligarchen machen Politik nach ihren
Interessen
sie tauschten einfach so Regierungen aus
fünf Regierungschefs innerhalb von drei
Jahren
ihren Reichtum bringen viele Oligarchen
aus Russland hinaus in Sicherheit in den
Westen
über den Dächern von Nizza lebt einer
der strittens hier der 90er Jahre
bekannt als bankier-
[Musik]
machte seine Milliarden mit einer Bank
Schiffswerften und Bauunternehmen mit
seiner englischen Frau Alexandra lebt
pugatschow viele Jahre den perfekten
Oligarchen Traum
dieser Umgang mit Geld war einfach irre
Sergej hatte zwei Privatjets und drei
Yachten wer braucht bitte zwei Jets und
drei Yachten wir machten Urlaub auf Sand
Barf in der Karibik
und nach einer Woche hatte er es gekauft
wir waren dort drei Monate im Jahr
mit dem Geld kommt die Macht pugatschow
gehört zu den einflussreichsten kramel
Oligarchen er soll den Machtwechsel
Organisieren von Boris Jelzin zu
Wladimir Putin
die Wahl sollte im Sommer sein Putin
konnte damals kein Mensch es war
unmöglich in den sechs Monaten zu einem
populären Kandidaten zu machen
könnte und Putin würde an seine Stelle
Rücken so konnte er ohne Wahl zum
Präsidenten werden und genauso kam es
dann ja auch
nach Jelzin wollen die Oligarchen weiter
die Politik bestimmen
das ist die standard definition von
Oligarchen Menschen die viel Geld und
große Macht in einer Hand vereinen
aber der neue Präsident hat ganz andere
Pläne
Entschuldigung
im Jahr 2000 gab es ein lockeres Treffen
der russischen Oligarchen mit Putin
Grillen in der Natur
Leute ihr mischt euch nicht in die
Politik ein und ich garantiere euch dass
es Euch weiterhin gut geht
der reichste der Reichen ist der
ölmagnet
er glaubte dass es keine Einmischung in
die Politik sei sich gegen Korruption
auszusprechen
die Korruption kostet Russland 30
Milliarden Dollar im Jahr das sind 10
bis 12% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts
von Regierungsbeamten
verstand nicht was er damit auslöste
weil er Putin nicht kannte
er wollte ihn nur auf etwas aufmerksam
machen
aber das kam als schwere Beleidigung
Anja Putin verstand das nämlich als
Angriff auf ihn und seine Leute
vielen Dank für Ihre Folien manche
Firmen wie etwa ihre Ölfirma haben
riesige Überschüsse an Öl wie kam es
dazu auch das muss Teil unserer Debatte
über Korruption sein
als ich das sah dachte ich oh Gott das
war's für ihn schade
[Musik]
kowski statuiert putinen Exempel nach
einem schau-prozess verschwindet er für
ein Jahrzehnt im Straflager
die Oligarchen sind für Putin Rivalen
und die macht den Medien
milliardärgustinski treibt der ins Exil
[Musik]
ebenso borisowski der wird 2013 erhängt
aufgefunden
an dieser Stelle muss man verstehen
Putin hat die Gruppe der Oligarchen
nicht etwa abgeschafft er tauschte aber
die Personen aus
[Musik]
der wohl bekannteste Oligarch kauft sich
in London einen ganzen Fußballclub mit
der Erlaubnis von Präsident Putin
Roman Abramowitsch hat seine Milliarden
im Ölgeschäft gemacht
Öl und Gas sind für den Krimi die
wichtigsten Ressourcen
[Musik]
Wladimir Putin ist Gas sehr wichtig und
genauso das Öl diese Geldquellen will er
kontrollieren und genau wissen wo das
Geld hingeht
[Musik]
ist investigativ Reporter beim Londoner
Guardian als Moskau Korrespondent
verfolgt er den Aufstieg einer neuen
Generation von Oligarchen unter Putin
[Musik]
in den 90ern gab es die wilde Oligarchen
Privatisierung der Öl- und Gaswirtschaft
mit Putin kam zwar keine allgemeine
wieder Verstaatlichung aber doch eine
Rückkehr bestimmter Unternehmen in
Staatsbesitz und die leiten nun Putins
Freunde
die Männer Freunde aus dem ST
Petersburger 90ern dort brachte es der
Ex Geheimagent Putin zum
Vizebürgermeister
[Musik]
putin war dieser nie lächelnde kleine
aufstrebende Funktion
war der Typ drei Schritte hinter ihm
buchstäblich sein Kofferträger
[Musik]
eine enge Beziehung und als Putin
Aufstieg stieg mit ihm auf
[Musik]
egorin folgt seine Meister in den Krümel
wo Putin ihn zum Vize-Chef der
Präsidialverwaltung macht
[Musik]
hier organisiert satch in den Showdown
mit dem Öl Oligarchen oder kowski
er war erst der Putin zu diesem Angriff
überredete und war zugleich hauptnutz
Nieser denn der Großteil von Roland
kowski ist Firma Jokos viel Anzeigen
bricht auseinander Schritt für Schritt
fallen Ölförderung Raffinerien
petruschemie an Bosnien Russlands größte
halbstadtliche Ölfirma
an der Spitze von rasnevt steht Igor
[Musik]
das Ölgeschäft von Rasen
2021 14 Milliarden Dollar reingewinner
ein Segen für den Staat und Putins
kriegsgasse aus Rivalen hat er Komplizen
gemacht
der Unterschied zwischen den 90ern und
heute ist dass die Oligarchen damals die
Entscheidung des Staates direkt
beeinflussten in der innen und
Wirtschaftspolitik in der Außenpolitik
in Sicherheitsfragen die Vorstandschefs
der heutigen Unternehmen haben solche
Privilegien nicht mehr
[Musik]
wurde beauftragt den Besitz des
aufmüpfigen Oligarchen rhodokowski zu
übernehmen aber nicht für sich privat
sondern um alles an den Start zu
überführen
natürlich behandelt er es wie seinen
Privatbesitz und zieht daraus alle
möglichen Vorteile aber nur solange er
Chef von Rosneft bleibt
[Musik]
auf die Loyalität seines taschenträgers
kann sich Putin verlassen ja für ja
dasselbe Ritual Zäpfchen berichtet an
seinen ewigen Chef
ich freue mich sehr Ihnen hier eine
Probe von unseren neuesten Ölquelle
präsentieren zu dürfen
aus dem Osten
natürlich besser als die bisherigen
natürlich viel besser
wer Öl kontrolliert der der kontrolliert
im Prinzip auch das Funktionieren das
russischen Staates in der Hinsicht war
es für Putin zentral diese diese
Privatisierung der 90er Jahre wieder
rückgängig zu machen zu verstaatlichen
und systematisch diese diese Firma unter
Kontrolle zu bringen
auch Russlands Gas Barone Arbeiten für
die Agenda des kremme das weltgrößte
Förderunternehmen Gazprom ist in der
Hand seiner Leute an der Spitze steht
seit mehr als 20 Jahren Alexey Miller
[Musik]
ihn kennt Putin ebenfalls seit den Tagen
im Rathaus von St Petersburg
millas einzige Qualifikation für den
Top-Job der russischen Wirtschaft ist
bedingungslose treuer
unter Miller wächst der halbstaatliche
Gazprom-Konzern zu einem Geflecht aus
Tochterfirmen und Beteiligungen
darunter sind Pipeline-Betreiber Banken
und Medienhäuser
die Bosse waren früher beim KGB oder
ähnlichen Diensten so wie Wladimir Putin
allein aus dem Energiesektor kommen bis
zu 40% des russischen Staatshaushalts
das Geschäft mit dem Gas dient dabei
auch als außenpolitische einflusswaffe
gerade unsere deutschen Freunde dürften
das doch am besten wissen Gazprom ist
eins der wichtigsten geopolitischen
Instrumente des Kreml wenn wir wollen
dann öffnen wir die Leitung und das Gas
fließt und wenn wir nicht mehr wollen
drehen wir den Hahn einfach zu das
funktioniert allerdings nur wenn es
einen hohen Grad von Abhängigkeit gibt
den Westen verachten und lieben die
Oligarchen zugleich
vor allem den Lifestyle Nizza hat als
Sehnsuchtsort der Russen Tradition die
orthodoxe Kathedrale ist über 100 Jahre
alt
das Geld der Russen war im Westen immer
hoch willkommen nicht nur in Frankreich
in Nizza lebt Annika Jöris für das
investigativer Recherche Team Korrektiv
hat sie ihre konstruiert wie der
russische gastprom-konzern die deutsche
Politik bis zur kommunalen Ebene hin
vereint hat
in Deutschland tritt Gazprom als Partner
des Westens auf als Förderer des Sports
und als zuverlässiger Gaslieferant über
die gemeinsame Nord Stream Pipeline
dafür arbeiten deutsche und russische
Politiker Hand in Hand
eine Lobby nennt das Annika Jöris
muss man sich vorstellen wie einfach ein
sehr erfolgreiches Netzwerk von Menschen
die Einfluss haben und je näher man dran
geht je genauer man guckt sieht man dann
es sind eigentlich letztendlich doch nur
15 20 entscheidende Personen
Protagonisten in diesem Netzwerk die uns
in Russland ausgeliefert haben
letztendlich
dieses Netzwerk verbreitet auf
Konferenzen und Begegnungen vor allem in
Ostdeutschland die Botschaft Russland
ist ein guter Partner Russland ist
zuverlässig Russland liefert immer
zum Beispiel Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in
diversen lobby-organisationen engagieren
sich die immer gleichen Landespolitiker
und russlandfreunde
von dort führt der Weg über Verbindungen
zu Nord Stream weiter zum eigentlichen
Sponsor am Ende steht halt immer Gasprom
also wenn da unten nur um das u-sommer
Musikfestival geht dann wird sie
irgendwie ganz nett und und harmlos an
sicherlich auch eine schöne
Veranstaltung aber hinter dem Sponsoring
wenn man dann weiter zurückgeht steht
dann irgendwie vielleicht Nord Stream
und Nord Stream ist dann wiederum
natürlich abhängig von Gasform und
Gasform von Putin
für diction Deutschlands Abhängigkeit
vom russischen Gas ist wohl der größte
politische Fehler der Nachkriegszeit
of the person
diese Abhängigkeit sollte der Bau der
Pipeline Nord Stream 2 besiegeln bis
Vladimir Putin mit seinem Ukraine Krieg
seine eigene Strategie pulverisierte
[Musik]
vor den Toren moskauz steht ein
oligarchens plien der Extraklasse der
zarenhafte millerhof von gasparone
Alexei Müller
doch der Reichtum der neuen Oligarchen
ist nur geliehen
in Russland gibt es keine Trennung vom
Staat deine 20 Milliarden sind schön und
gut solange sie dir der Staat nicht
wegnimmt also denkst du nur daran wie du
sie behalten und deinen Draht zur Macht
pflegen kannst denn wenn dieser Draht
zum Kreml reist verlierst du alles dein
Geld und vielleicht sogar dein Leben
[Musik]
der elitenforscher Nikolai Petrov
analysiert die Beziehung der russischen
Großunternehmer zur Macht und wie sie
sich in den Jahren von Jelzin des Putin
verändert hat
petra hat beobachtet dass der Kreml
unter Putin die Reichen zunehmend für
staatliche Aufgaben einspannt
sie sollen nach den Exzessen der 90er
Jahre der russischen Gesellschaft etwas
von ihrem unerhörten Reichtum
zurückgeben
eine Weile lang verfolgte der Kreml die
Idee besonders verarmte Regionen
Russlands in die Obhut von Oligarchen zu
geben
diese sollten dort mit ihren
Privatmitteln die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung voranbringen
acht Jahre lang regiert Roman Abramovic
als Gouverneur die sibirische
Arktisregion zu Kotka nach eigenen
Angaben steckt er an die 300 Millionen
Dollar im Schulen Krankenhäuser und
einen Flughafen
nur ich kann hirschner
mehrmals darum gebeten diesen Posten
abzugeben
Putin ließ ihn aber nicht gehen
wird im Grunde bis heute von abramowitz
Leuten gemanagt
die Rotenberg ist ein Judo Partner
Putins aus Leningrad Zeit er steigt in
die Oligarchen Klasse auf weil er für
den alten Freund staatliche
mega-bauprojekte umsetzen darf
[Musik]
nannte man den Champion des
staatsauftrags
als Bauunternehmer kümmert sich
Rotenberg um Putins Prestige Vorhaben
wie die Brücke vom russischen Festland
zur annektierten Krim nicht nur der
technische Aufwand macht solche Vorhaben
immens teuer
Gutenberg bekommt diesen Auftrag zeigt
damit Loyalität und gleichzeitig
eröffnet ihm dass die Möglichkeit sich
selbst zu bereichern jeder Kilometer
Straße in Russland kostet ein Mehrfaches
als wenn er jetzt in europäischen
Ländern gebaut wird einfach weil rund um
diesen Bau von Infrastruktur sehr sehr
viel Geld verdient wird zusätzlich
Vladimir Putin sitzt am Steuer eines
Systems an dem sich viele bereichern
aber indem am Ende immer nur einer das
Sagen hat
[Musik]
seitdem ist
materia genau genommen betrachtet der
Kreml alle Oligarchen wie angestellte
Manager die große Besitztümer zu
verwalten haben
aber eben unter strenger Kontrolle
eine Kontrolle bis ins Privatleben so
gilt für die Kreml Manager eine Frau aus
dem Westen zu heiraten entspricht nicht
dem Kodex
[Musik]
überrascht
wieso denn eine Engländerin was soll das
in Russland leben über 140 Millionen
Menschen ich sagte ja klar aber sie lebt
nun mal leider in London oder zum Glück
er sagte komisch es ist eine seltsame
Idee ich sagte na ja mal sehen
[Musik]
ihre Ehe mit Putins Banker führt die
junge Alexandra tollstreu aus der
britischen heiße City in den Fremden
Kosmos der russischen Kreml Oligarchen
ich arbeitete für den lorious Sports
Award da gab es eine große Gala in St
Petersburg mit vielen Oligarchen
putin war auch da
und da beobachtete ich etwas seltsames
als Putin ging stand ich neben Sergej
sie blickten sich an und Sergej ist viel
größer als Putin aber er verbeugte sich
und Putin machte irgendwie so das war
richtig feudal wie am mittelalterlichen
Hof
[Musik]
mir schien Putin eifersüchtig zu sein
auf dieses Leben mit den Yachten und den
tollen Reisen während er in seinem öden
Russland fest saß
diese Leute hatten ihn an die Macht
gebracht nun wurde er sie nach und nach
los
für seine Kriegspläne rüstet Putin das
Militär auf dafür braucht er das Geld
der Oligarchen und ihre Industrie
so wie die Schiffswerften von Sergej
poggerschow in St Petersburg
wollte den staatlichen Anteil an der
Rüstungsindustrie aufstocken und machte
daher pugatsch ein Angebot für seine
Unternehmensanteile
war damit nicht so ohne weiteres
einverstanden
sie ihm einfach wegzunehmen
irgendeinen finanzgleichung aktiviere
der Kreml überzieht pogatschow mit
Steuerverfahren und Betrugsvorwürfen und
verklagt ihn sogar in London
der flüchtet ohne seine Familie nach
Frankreich
aber selbst hier spüren ihn hochrangige
Abgesandte des Kreml auf
bei diesem Treffen war der Chef der
russischen Steuerbehörde dabei sie luden
mich in ein Restaurant am Hafen ein und
sagten mir entweder du bezahlst 350
Millionen oder wir töten dich oder deine
Familie
wir könnten deinem Sohn die Finger
abschneiden und sie dir zuschicken es
war wie bei der Mafia
seit seiner Flucht sollen drei Anschläge
auf pugatschows Leben verübt worden sein
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja ja jedes Jahr veröffentlicht
der kreml-zahlen zu Wladimir Putins
offiziellem Vermögen
eine 77 Quadratmeter Wohnung eine Garage
ein Jahreseinkommen von 114.000 Euro und
alle Berichte über ein Milliarden
Vermögen sein Fake
nichts von dem was dort als mein
Eigentum bezeichnet wird gehört mir
oder mein näheren Verwandten
nichts
im Kreis seiner Kreml vertrauten hat
Putin allerdings nie ein Geheimnis aus
seinen gehobenen Ansprüchen an Wohlstand
gemacht
von Milliarden war damals zwar noch
keine Rede Putin meinte er bleibt eine
Weile und dann wird jemand anderes
gefunden aber dafür müsste er eine große
Aufwandsentschädigung bekommen eine die
es ihm für den Rest seines Lebens
erlauben würde ruhig glücklich und
Wohlhaben zu
lebende Wort
der Staatspräsident und seine schwarzen
Kassen
Spuren davon finden sich in den Panama
papers jeder Sammlung geheimer
finanzdokumente durch die Tausende
Briefkastenfirmen in Steueroasen
öffentlich wurden da wo die Superreichen
ihr Geld verstecken
[Musik]
als ich Zugang zu dieser magischen
Datenbank mit offshore Geheimnissen
erhielt war das wie eine Schatzkammer
und zum großen Teil lagen das Schätze
aus Russland
wir stießen auf einen gewissen Sergej
und fragten uns wer ist denn Sergej
er stellte sich heraus dass er ein
Cellist aus St Petersburg ist from
[Musik]
Dirigent und Leiter des Hauses der Musik
in St Petersburg ein ehrenwerter
Künstler hinter dem niemand große
Geldströme vermuten würde
doch genau dieser rollt dugen verbirgt
sich in den Daten der Panama papers
hinter einem ganzen Ring von
offshore-firmen mit einem Gesamtwert von
4 Milliarden Dollar
Herkunft und ziel dieses Geldes ist
Russland genauer der kremme
wie kommt ein bescheidener Musiker in
den geldwäschekreislauf des
kremlapparates
[Musik]
in den 70er Jahren war Putin ein
angehender Spion und rolldogin ein
Nachwuchsmusiker gemeinsam gegen sie auf
double Dates mit zwei jungen Frauen aus
Leningrad eine davon eine blondes
Stewardess von Aeroflot diese Ludmilla
wurde Putins Ehefrau
der Pate ihrer ersten Tochter
bis heute sind sie enge Freunde
Putin seinen Bruder
[Musik]
uns nichts dazu sagen aber Putin selbst
hat die Geschichte gar nicht dementiert
er hat gesagt dass diese Milliarden für
den Kauf von Musikinstrumenten für
Russland waren ein patriotischer Akt
die Panama papers legen nah das Putin
seiner autorei als Stadthalter und
Brieftasche für eine riesen Vermögen
benutzt ohne dass sein eigener Name
jemals offiziell auftaucht
Putin hat während seiner Herrschaft ein
System von Platzhaltern entwickelt
rolldugien ist einer von mehreren
es sind eher Verwalter von Geld dass
ihnen nicht wirklich gehört das im
Prinzip dem Kreml oder dem Putin selbst
oder seinem Umfeld gehört
Putins Palast ein investigativfilm der
oppositionellen navi-gruppe enthüllt
diese Residenz mit allem Oli gleichen
Überfluss Bauherr soll Präsident Putin
sein doch mitten in die Empörung meldet
sich der König der Staatsaufträge AK die
Rotenberg mit einer gegenenthüllung
das war ein recht kompliziertes
Bauprojekt
da gab es viele Kreditgeber und mir ist
es gelungen Eigentümer zu werden das ist
ein Geschenk des Himmels einfach
wunderschön
experten schätzen Putins Vermögen auf 60
Milliarden Dollar aufgeteilt auf einen
Kreis von Platzhaltern und Strohmännern
staatsvermögen und persönlicher Reichtum
sind eins Geld und Macht symbiotisch
verschmolzen
Jenny wohl sehen
Geld bedeutet für Putin macht
deswegen braucht er mehr Geld als jeder
andere im Land und in seinem Umfeld
eine mafiösen Struktur und alle seine
Untergebenen haben in diesem System
bestimmte Aufgaben
der eine ist fürs Geschäft und die
Finanzen zuständig jemand ist für die
blutigen Angelegenheiten da und jemand
dritte management
[Musik]
mit dem Überfall auf die Ukraine stehen
die Oligarchen vor einer Zeitenwende
[Musik]
ein Treffen im Kreml wie vor 20 Jahren
so wie damals fordert der Präsident auch
diesmal ihre unbedingte Gefolgschaft
in diesem Zusammenhang appelliere ich an
sie zeigen sie Verständnis für die
aktuelle Lage und arbeiten Sie
solidarisch mit der Regierung um
Produktion Wirtschaft und Arbeitsplätze
zu erhalten nehmen Sie die Realitäten an
die sich gerade ergeben
[Musik]
das zeigt den Unterschied zwischen dem
der die Entscheidungen trifft und jenen
die nur die Folgen tragen dürfen
der Krieg in der Ukraine setzt die
meisten Oligarchen unterschock doch er
ist auch ein neues Geschäftsmodell eine
Chance auf noch mehr Geld und noch mehr
Nähe zu den herrschenden im Kremmel das
ist das Kalkül eines extra links und neu
olligarchen der sein Vermögen in der
Gastronomie gemacht hat
gfgeni prikosin aus St Petersburg erst
hatte er nur einen Hotdog stand dann ein
Restaurant und schließlich einen
Stammkunden
Vladimir Putin
pregorian serviert persönlich auf Banken
für Putins ihren gestern seine Catering
Firma kommt dann öffentliche Aufträge
wie Schulspeisungen dank Putin
ihn selbst nennt man inzwischen Putins
Koch
en ein guter Koch muss die Wünsche
seines Kunden erahnen darauf hat rigosch
ihn gebaut und seinen Weg nach oben
beschritten
mit dem Stolz eines neureichen
präsentiert Jewgeni pregoschin einem
deutschen Kamerateam seine Villa und
seinen wichtigen Freund
[Musik]
Gregorian stößt in die Lücke die die
anderen Oligarchen gelassen haben das
Geschäft mit Tod und Gewalt
[Musik]
mit dem Wohlwollen des Kreml finanziert
er privatkriege wo die russische Armee
nicht hinkommt seine Söldnergruppe
Wagner operiert verdeckt in Syrien und
Afrika ganz offen kämpft sie heute in
der Ukraine als private parallelarmee
erfüllt die Rolle des Killers er ist
einer der für das Regime die schmutzige
blutige Arbeit erledigt
persönlich rekrutierte er in Russland
Gefängnissen Verbrecher und Häftlinge
als Soldaten für seine Wagner Armee im
Ukraine Krieg
ist der Hotliner unter den Oligarchen
[Musik]
öffentlich verunglimpft er die russische
Militärführung und inszeniert sich als
Warlord
den Krieg sieht er als die Chance seines
Lebens
[Musik]
er nutzt die Lage ganz berechnend für
sich aus Geld steht bei ihm an erster
Stelle und er nutzt die Gelegenheit um
noch mehr Geld zu verdienen
der kriegsgewinner unter Russlands
reichen gesucht mit einem
internationalen Haftbefehl
und mitten in London Grad werden Häuser
der Oligarchen befreit wie die Besetzer
sagen
wegen ihrer Verbindungen zum
putin-regime sind sie sanktioniert und
ihre Vermögen festgesetzt
sie geben Interviews in Londoner
Zeitungen wo sie beklagen dass ihre
Bankkarte am Automaten nicht mehr
funktioniert
ihr müsst euch entscheiden sagte ich
Ihnen sonst bekommt ihr Sanktionen sie
sagten aber warum wir wir haben nichts
getan das ist doch alles der Putin da
wir machen nur still und leise unser
Ding und ich sagte ihnen nein ihr zahlt
Steuern und damit werden Waffen gekauft
viele von euch haben Rüstungsfirmen
diese Erkenntnis kommt bei ihnen nur
langsam an
trotz aller Verluste kommt aus den
Reihen der russischen Oligarchen kein
Widerspruch gegen putinskrieg
bis heute nicht
gestorben
[Musik]
am Ende hat Putins spielen ihr
Lebensmodell zerstört
Gruppe für die Gruppe der russischen
Oligarchen bedeutet dieser Krieg den
Putin begonnen hat das Ende jener Welt
in der sie Jahrzehnte lang gelebt haben
sie verlieren eigentlich alles sie
können nicht mehr reisen ihre Assets
werden beschlagnahmt ihre Firmen werden
zerschlagen in Teilen und sie sind noch
abhängiger abhängiger im Prinzip vom
Kreml um auch ökonomisch zu überleben
also sie werden im Prinzip als Gruppe
abgeschafft
[Musik]
vor 20 Jahren hoben Russlands Oligarchen
Wladimir Putins an nun zahlen Sie den
Preis für seine mörderische Politik
[Musik]